[Music]
john kicks us off this hour in vancouver
canada john welcome to the ramsay show
welcome hello can you hear me sure how
can i help
so i'm planning to buy an electric
vehicle in the near future
okay
it's yeah it'll be my first vehicle
purchase wow
cool how old are you yeah
uh 25 25 okay
have you been driving uh something else
that is not yours yeah my parents cars
yeah okay cool
all right so what's your question
i'm just looking at like because like we
have a carbon tax in canada and it's
like
keeps going up every year you know
that you pay on gas vehicles if you own
a gas vehicle you have to pay an extra
tax
yeah
what is the tax you know
it's
right now it's about 10 cents a liter
okay
for carbon so it keeps going up every
year
and i'm trying to
think about you know switching to an
electric and buying one for myself and
the potential savings and
yeah all right so uh are you
do you have any debt right now
no no i have no debt i have about 50 000
in savings wow
good and another 20 20 000 and
a tax-free savings account which is like
a roth ira and then i have another 20
000 and uh rsp which is like a 401k
good for you
man you've been crushing it what do you
do for a living
i work in warehousing i operate a
forklift and do a bunch of distribution
and stuff what's your income
it is right now 60 000
a year okay and have you researched
these electric vehicles you know which
one you want what the price point would
be
uh yes i've looked at it i've also
looked at rebates and stuff like for
buying electric vehicles as well
sure both federal and provincial
okay so what's the price of this car if
you went onto the lot and bought it
today without any of the rebates toyota
rav4 prime it's around fifty thousand
dollars
oh boy
yeah dude that's almost your entire
income
tied up in a depreciating asset yeah
were you listening to that last call
no i'm just building my income this is
like not like current years a few years
in the future because it's at least a
one year waiting list for these electric
vehicles okay so you're going to keep
driving your parents car until you
purchase a vehicle
yes and
you're doing this to save money
uh yes yes so we're gonna spend fifty
thousand dollars
to save money
in the long term yes
but do you understand
the difference
you could buy a fifteen thousand 000 car
which means you would have to be paying
35 000 extra in carbon tax and
gas and all of these things in order to
make up for the fact that you bought a
50 000 electric car
no i understand it's not i'm just
looking at all these electric bills
that's why i'm thinking long term not
um
i understand this for thinking long term
we've got to realize that cars are
depreciating asset whether they're gas
or
no i understand i understand that well
i'm not trying to beat up on you i just
want to think through this critically
with no i know i that's why i'm planning
like looking at all the numbers and i
just wanted some advice from your end
well we also don't recommend you buy a
new car unless you are a millionaire
because you can't take the hit on
depreciation making 60k a year buying a
50 000 car that's going to depreciate
every single month yeah and so if i'm
you if you're going to make 60k let's
say a year from now you're still making
about 60k it's not going to go up to 200
000 in warehousing
so what i want you to do is take 30 or
less and buy you a used electric car if
that's something that you're still
wanting
okay i'm just no there's cheaper
electric cars so i'm just looking at all
the ones that have rebate options
but
if you spend 50 grand and get a 5 000
rebate you still spent 45 thousand
dollars
if you bought a 20 000 electric car with
no rebate you still saved thirty
thousand dollars
do you see the math i'm doing here yeah
you know i know i know so i don't want
your judgment to get clouded by rebates
and credits and
because truthfully it you want the
newest shiny electric vehicle right i
mean who wants to drive a used one if
you could drive a new one
i just don't think the used electric
vehicles are
that plentiful but because there's
already a waiting list for new electric
vehicles in canada or where i live in
vancouver at least
well they're out there you might have to
get there first i mean it's like a hot
home market you just might need to get
there first yeah and be willing to to
negotiate or you know pay full price or
whatever they're asking but i'm still if
i'm you dude you're just so young you've
got your whole life ahead of you i don't
want you spending all this savings that
you've worked so hard for to go into a
depreciating asset
okay it's gonna be nice as soon as you
drive it off the line
no i understand i'm just thinking like
from 10 years from now 20 because like
the industry is going to change to the
point where they're going to
only make electric vehicles in 2030 2040
or something well by then we'll all live
on mars and we won't even have to deal
with cars anymore
i'm just saying i don't want you
worrying about what's going to happen 10
years from now i want you to do what's
right for you right now and what makes
sense for your future and right now
you're you're 25 years old you're making
60k you've done really well and i don't
want to see that money disappear into
this electric vehicle because you you
see the shiny lights of credits and
rebates
you know what i mean it still doesn't
make it a wise no i know i i understand
i understand it's just i'm thinking you
know this change is going to happen
within my generation within my lifetime
so and when it does we'll deal with it
but right now you can afford 10 cents on
a liter even if you didn't get an
electric car
yeah it's just gas is getting up and up
it's like pretty crazy up here now it's
like around five dollars us a gallon
what's your commutes like where are you
going to working back
yeah just to working back what's that
commute
it's like about
pretty short like 30 to 50 kilometers
okay something like that is pretty short
yeah well it's not that big you're good
at math you're you're a wise dude and so
do the math on this and go all right
here's really what i'm spending on gas
realistically not how i feel about it
but do the math on i go this many
kilometers here's the 10 cents per liter
here's what that really amounts to in my
given week and you go okay it's about 30
bucks a week for me to to get around
town in this non-electric vehicle
and the truth is you can afford it
you're not really saving that much money
in the long run you're already doing
great saving for retirement doing all
these different things and so i i don't
want you to justify the electric vehicle
purchase because of the money savings
because truthfully it takes a long time
to to get a return on investment when
buying that electric vehicle especially
if it's new
okay
let's see you're doing great man
i love canadians they're so nice john
you're an awesome dude i'm so proud of
you you've done so well i don't want you
to move backwards by spending 50 000 on
a car when you make 60. it's just not a
wise move right now later on down the
road you're making 120 000 you're a
millionaire go ahead and buy you a 50
000 brand new electric vehicle and give
me a call back i might be 58 years old
by then hopefully i'm still doing the
show